make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and
before we start this video I want to pop
a question to you guys will you marry me
I do want to ask you all a question
though I had a fan send me a message on
I think an email or on discord telling
me that like they basically put my
videos on to help their baby fall asleep
right they have like a little baby kid
and they you know my videos help them
fall asleep because my voice is so
relaxing and so I asked people on
Twitter I said if I had a channel where
I read you guys bedtime stories would
you watch it but because I'm considering
just like repurposing one of the older
channels that I have that I don't use
your don't want to have like 15 channels
running around right so I figured I'm
you know if people were interested in it
I would like repurpose a channel for
that right and then just like read you
guys bedtime stories would you guys
watch that or listen to it rather like
would you guys dig something like that
feel like people would say yes I don't
really know but what I want to do in
this video and really what I want to do
this week is I want to essentially
create a big event in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
right now you know something on par with
like Avengers infinity war and Avengers
in game now spoiler alert the event that
we're gonna be creating here is gonna be
Secret Wars and so what we're gonna do
is we're going to run a series of movies
that are gonna do exactly what the first
10 years of the MCU did and start
breaking things down now one big caveat
to understand here is there's two things
the MCU has come out and said right
Feige and company have come out and said
two big things the first is they're not
gonna do what they did before which is a
phase of movies and then Avengers and
then like another phase of movies and
then like Avengers 2 and then Avengers 3
and so on they're not gonna do that
right and said everything's gonna be
broken down into like five phases or so
and some of these may have like a big
event and some of them may not we don't
know exactly what form is going to take
that's really all they've given us and
so because of that because we're looking
at anywhere between three to five year
long arcs I've basically scaled this
accordingly right and I've also kind of
scaled down the amount of movies that
we're gonna be getting to just because
of the fact that Marvel as far as I'm
aware is focusing both on movies and on
TV shows now right so that kind of takes
away half the attention the other part
of this is that finding them said it's
going to be at least five years before
we see the x-men or any of the x-men
related properties in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe largely because it
looks like they've got other things that
they were working on before they got to
this point so I'm also taking that into
account and so what we're gonna do here
is we're gonna initially kind of open up
with some of the movies that have
already been slated right so we have
Black Widow the Eternals shang-chi and
The Legend of the ten rings spider-man 3
4 for Doctor Strange - black panther 2
and Captain Marvel
- only a few of these movies were
actually going to focus on and it's
because things like the Black Widow
movie or flashbacks there's gonna be a
flashback films we know she's dead after
the events of Avengers in a game like
she cannot come back
I guess maybe they can barter her soul
if they travel to the realm of mistress
death we don't really know if that's an
option but it looks like Scarlett
Johansson is just out forevermore with
regards to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
movies with something like shang-chi and
the ten rings no clue what they're gonna
do with that right Shane she was always
only really ever at best a street-level
character that doesn't mean it's bad it
just means who knows what they're gonna
do here and then it'd been really the
uncertainty with what could be done with
this film is actually what makes me even
more excited for us spider-man 3 we
don't really know what form this is
gonna take because we don't know what
the future of spider-man in moral
Cinematic Universe is gonna be I do have
a big plan that's very similar to this
in terms of what to do with spider-man
if he reverts back to Sony so that Sony
can create a series of films that will
essentially be their own version of like
infinity war and Avengers in game and
that I think they would really have a
lot to contribute to the Sony landscape
right and so what this does is it
basically brings us in to really kind of
it kind of lets us go back to the
Eternals right so talking about the
Eternals for a second by whatever manner
and whatever means I don't know exactly
how this movie's gonna unfold we're
gonna have Cersei right we're gonna have
Icarus we're gonna have those characters
but I think the big takeaway from this
needs to be that one is going to set the
ground level for how mutants come into
the MCU and two it'll give us some book
ended origin on fan OHS not that it
matters because Thanos has been defeated
but it would still be a nice little
tribute in a way to basically have a
film that kind of ties back into the
last 10 years that we've experienced now
if those guys who don't know the basis
behind the organ of mutants is that in
the early days of mankind you basically
had the missing link right they were
called The Wanderers the the gap between
primate man and modern man and the
Wanderers were met by Gaia who was the
sentience of Earth basically mother
earth I doubt they'd do that in the
Eternals movie but essentially she
basically guided them towards Celestials
and the Celestials ended up taking the
Wanderers and splitting them into thirds
the first third had their genes modified
so they would basically become perfect
in nature like they would be angelic in
terms of their appearance they'd be able
to tap into cosmic energy they basically
went forward as the Eternals the job of
the Eternals was to safeguard baseline
humanity now the second group had their
genes destabilized and the idea behind
having their genes destabilized was to
simply just create rampant unchecked
mutations with no real indication of how
they would unfold right that group
became a deviance and the deviance
largely resided undergrad
for time and in the third group had
their genes modified in such a way so
that they would begin the process of
mutating at some future point in time
now how these mutations would end up
manifesting but we weren't really given
a timetable for it was just somewhere
along the line they're going to manifest
and in truth it was actually the
Celestials looking for a particular end
result and that end result actually came
in the form of Franklin Richards but the
fact remains here that that third group
the genes that were modified so that
they would start activating at some
point in time that's where your mutants
come from now in terms of the overall
role the Eternals just kind of give you
guys a little bit of a perspective here
the trails were designed for
safeguarding humanity to make sure that
they were basically Shepherds for
Humanity who were perceived to be sheep
right not really literally but
metaphorically what ended up happening
here is that the Eternals abandon their
duties they abandon their post and this
left that led deviance to enslaving
humanity
now the Celestials return during what
was called the second host and they
realized the Eternals had vacated their
role and so they punished the deviants
by basically wiping out pretty much all
of them pushing them to the brink of
extinction and what was called the great
Cataclysm and that led to the sinking of
Atlantis right so initially the divi in
capital city was called lumeria
and so with Atlantis sinking underwater
the deviants were basically forced to
reside underground and then the Eternals
were tasked with basically safeguarding
humanity or keeping an eye on humanity
and doing what they were supposed to do
now the Razr the reason why this would
have bookends into the origin of Thanos
is because what you also had leading up
to and around that time is you had some
Eternals who actually left earth and
they took up residence on Saturn's moon
Titan and so where there ended up being
a civil war among those Titanian
Eternals but there was only one woman
left named sweet son right she ended up
basically being being the the sole
survivor and so when there was a second
exodus of eternals some of those who
were led by not highfather who were led
by a camera what his name was it's like
father or something like that anyway who
were led by that guy he ended up
marrying sweet son and they had a couple
of kits they had starfox and then they
also had Thanos right or Eros and
Thanatos so that's what you want to call
them so you know Thanos was basically is
is rooted in humanity right like his
genes can be traced back to essentially
the missing link between humans and
mutants so you know there's there's an
argument there to basically say
Pharaoh's is essentially an earth born
being right just you can trace his
heritage back to that point but
nonetheless okay so so so jumpy past
that that's really the big takeaway
right eternals is going to lay tits lay
the foundation and say this is where
mutants come from right now skipping
over Shane cheese skipping over
spider-man 3 jump into Thor 4 this is
really probably just going to be an
those buddy-cop kind of movies it falls
in line with thor ragnarok as well as
the events of guardians of the galaxy -
we know that Jane Foster is supposed to
get the hammer right we know that kind
of thing is supposed to happen what I'm
also hoping here is this introduces Adam
warlock instead of having a situation
like you saw in Marvel Comics when Adam
warlock first emerged miss cocoon for
the very first time and then tried to
take SIF as his as his bride instead he
tries to take Jane Foster and this
basically leads to Thor intervening and
were to save Jane Foster from Adam
warlock or something along those lines
it's kind of far-fetched because we
don't really have any reason to believe
that Adam warlock would be knowledgeable
about earth or have any interest in
earth and so at that point we just kind
of throw in whatever explanation we want
to in order to make that work right it
could be that like Thor in the guardians
of the galaxy or all from space and
basically Adam warlock emerged as a
result of Thanos blinking out half the
life in the universe you know it was
essentially the race that created am i
captain were their names where they
basically the sovereign they basically
panicked right when half their rage got
wiped out they're like oh my god is some
crazy threat we have to release Adam so
we can defeat this threat and then they
hit the hit the big red button and the
cocoon opened up and then Adam warlocks
been here ever since we can throw in
whatever explanation that we want to but
basically that's where you would see
Adam warlock introduced now in terms of
building up to secret Wars this comes
with Doctor Strange - the idea behind
Doctor Strange - the multiverse of
madness is this is most likely going to
see the introduction of a villain like
nightmare or possibly even Dormammu
having a bigger role but we know the
Doctor Strange in the Scarlet Witch are
going to be a part of it now it'll
probably end up seeing alternate
realities that are out there somewhere
some may be references to films that
we've seen before back when Fox owned
the x-men of the Fantastic Four and all
that back when you know Sony when when
Spiderman was part of Sony so it'd be a
fun little easter egg you see like Tobey
Maguire spider-man and some universe
somewhere but regardless of what goes
down and this will likely focus on the
skull at which learning how to use her
powers learning that she can work
reality that she's far more powerful
than she believes she is but the big
takeaway from this is that the Beyonder
becomes aware of them because by some
manner either they get lost or whatever
the case is they end up outside the
multiverse and the beyond door basically
sees them and you know as you know when
they are when they're there for a moment
like okay we don't know where we are and
basically end up snapping back the
Beyonder becomes aware that there's life
outside of itself right so for those you
guys who don't know what this means in
model comics you have the Beyonder who's
literally called that because he hails
from a realm called the beyond verse now
there's two different iterations there's
the Beyonder as he originally appeared
in secret wars 1984 then there's the
Beyonder as you
reference during Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers we're gonna
gonna go with the original stuff we're
gonna take a little bit of Hickman's
Avengers New Avengers and kind of throw
some of those concepts in but for the
most part we're sticking largely with
the Beyonder and the way this worked in
Marvel was that any original Secret Wars
event and a kind of Cataclysm took place
they basically led to a sort of pinhole
tear in the fabric of the multiverse you
know and it allowed the Beyonder from
the beyond verse this space that makes
the multiverse look absolutely tiny
right which is kind of weird I don't
know how you make an infinitely
expansive space look small but uh but
nonetheless the Beyonder basically
realized the Marvel multiverse was there
and the Beyonder started looking in and
became curious unlike the nature of good
and evil and this led the Beyonder
entering the main Marvel Universe and
that's how we got Secret Wars right so
we would basically take that concept and
we would say the Doctor Strange and
Scarlet Witch traveling the multiverse
somehow ending up outside of it in what
amounts to you a five to ten minute long
scene was enough for the Beyonder to
become aware of their existence and then
essentially follow them back and then
became curious about everything that
exists inside the entirety of the Marvel
multiverse right so from there go into
black panther 2 and black panther 2 I
would make this movie doom war basically
is what it would be and the reason why
is because it's a great way to introduce
the character of Doctor Doom now we
don't need a great big huge amount of
exposition we can get it we can get this
kind of origin of Doctor Doom or we can
at least come to the understanding that
he leads Latveria and you can introduce
Latveria in any number of ways right you
could say that Latveria was part of the
Eastern Bloc of communist Russia and
that when the Soviet Union fell at the
end of the Cold War that Liberia was any
number of other countries who are
basically just liberated from the yoke
of oppression and communism and we're
basically told here you go you're free
good luck
try to make it work and this led to dr.
doom basically seizing control now we
end up seeing things like dr. doom is
not a dictator he's not cruel that he
loves his people and he'll do over it
whatever it takes to protect them but
regardless of the circumstance dr. doom
becomes aware of vibranium in Wakanda
and it becomes aware of the fact that
vibranium has the ability to amplify
magical energy and so in response to
this dr. doom basically ends up
orchestrating a coup d'etat in the
country of Wakanda which basically
allows individuals who are kind of
remnants from the the era of Erik Hill
manga right when Erik Hill monger popped
up and said I'm the rightful heir to the
throne that there's fallout from from
Black Panther killing him but there are
still people who were loyal to Erik Hill
monger or who never saw Black Panther as
an adequate king who wanted to return to
the ways of old and that this
their opportunity to do that right dr.
Doom's like you know where Eric hill
monger failed I can succeed you know I
will put you guys in power you can get
Black Panthers out and they successfully
do right but in the process much like in
the comics
T'Challa is injured and he has to pass
the mantle a black panther to his sister
and so sure he becomes a new black
panther and they're just kind of
proceeds however in the Hecate proceeds
after that well you know whatever it is
whatever it ends up taking place right
the long and short of it is that Black
Panther T'Challa as a superhero that we
know for a time is not truly black
panther maybe he gets those abilities
back right and him getting those
abilities back is actually pretty
important for what we end up doing later
on down the line in a different video
but what we end up doing here is we
basically kind of skim over Captain
Marvel - that movie will be whatever
that movie is right maybe it introduces
spectrum Monica Rambeau don't really
know but at that point we jump into new
material we jump into new faces and what
we do here is we pick up with Excalibur
now Excalibur is is basically Britain's
superhero team and they've been around
for quite some time and in fact
Excalibur as far as I'm aware was
actually the answer or at least well as
in the way that we're gonna do it in in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Excalibur is going to be the answer to
the disbanded Avengers team by the fact
of the Avengers team doesn't really
exist anymore in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe right like Captain America's
retired Iron Man's dead
Hawkeye on the Hawkeye is basically he's
spending time with his family like
widows dead incredible hulks doing
whatever he's doing Thor's out in space
so there really is no more Avengers team
right the party's over and everybody's
gone home and but it responds to that
you basically have written that kind of
looks around and says okay but like if
there's no Avengers team to protect the
world and who's gonna protect us well we
have to be able to protect ourselves
this leads to the introduction of
Excalibur
now the first bit of this and this is
where things get pretty important here
the first bit of this is focusing on
Captain Britain right Brian Braddock
becoming Captain Britain it doesn't need
to be super long right half an hour
something along those lines but when he
just when he selects the the amulet of
right basically the artifact that gives
him his powers he's taken and basically
shown the captain britain cork that in
the entirety of the multiverse that
there's one captain britain in each
universe and that captain britain is
designed to try to safeguard the
universe as best he can which is a tall
order because captain britain can't
really do anything but fly and like
punch really hard and run fast music
Captain America that's like twice as
strong you know it's really not that
great of a hero and certainly completely
ill-equipped to protect the universe
from any real measurable threat that
could be a danger to the universe but
what this does is is while he's doing
his quote-unquote tour of the Captain
Britain core right
while he's being shown around whatever
the case says in the background we start
hearing things like Captain Britain's
you know the Captain Britain of this
universe has been destroyed the Captain
Britain of that universe has been
destroyed their universes have been
totally wiped out there's basically
pandemonium and panic going on out there
in the multiverse we don't really know
what it is right now the thing here is
this is basically building up to the
Beyonder that after the Beyonder
followed dr. strange and company into
the multiverse he started getting
curious and what could kind of a full
exposition of what's going on with
regards to what they'd be honours been
doing but the Beyonder kind of got
curious and by virtue of his actions has
led to the destruction of these
different universes it wasn't as if
those versions of Captain Britain
actively fought against the Beyonder it
was simply that they were destroyed
along with her he naver's maybe some of
them were destroyed in battle when they
tried to face the Beyonder maybe other
superheroes became aware of the Beyonder
will explain how all that works once we
get to the actual secret wars film but
following this what we do is we switch
over to Alpha Flight and what Alpha
Flight does is it introduces basically
this team that's government sanctioned
right it's it's just like Britain in
there Excalibur Canada has a team to
protect its own interest but the
difference here is that unlike in the
comics where Alpha Flight was always
basically a government-sanctioned team
what we throw in here is the idea that
at some point in the past off a flight
was a ragtag team right they were just
operating on a shoestring budget they
weren't government sanctioned there were
just people who took up arms to
basically protect their country as best
they could
but they were just kind of small it's
finding these small little skirmishes
they never really fought any major
threats you know anything like that
which is why we've never heard of them
but the reason why this matters and the
big takeaway from this is what you say
is that at the point when they were a
ragtag team Wolverine was part of Alpha
Flight because in the comics he was you
basically say that Wolverine served
alongside Alpha Flight doesn't have to
be a great big huge moment maybe it's
just kind of like well they're walking
through their office or something like
that you know whatever it is and they've
got their room and they've got
memorabilia from days gone by and
they've got a group picture and in that
group picture is Wolverine in as
Wolverine outfit but this sets the stage
for that it sets the stage for the
introduction of Wolverine and so
following this in the last movie that
we're gonna talk about in this video we
get into blue Marvel and blue Marvel I
feel like as a character who is long
overdue in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
he's he really deserves a movie right
but this movie much like the Black Widow
film is done as a flashback film in the
sense that what we end up doing is
basically getting the origin by Kevin
grievious for blue mark we make a few
changes here and there to try to make it
fit into continuity but you basically
end up saying that like in the 1960s
that Adam Brashear was a superhero right
he was a guy who saved the world from
multiple threats from asteroids and
alien invasions and all that kind of
stuff you know and in the midst of the
civil rights movement the country was
already chaotic but the blue Marvel was
a hero that that everybody could
effectively rally around and this was
all copacetic until he fought his
arch-nemesis a guy by the name of Connor
Sims also known as an T man and wear
blue Marvel did prove to be successful
his mask was torn and you end up finding
out he's a black man and the black
community basically says well because
you're black you have to ally yourself
with us the white community and the
federal government panics that says if
he does that there'll be nothing we can
do to stop him and so much like what you
saw in the comic President Kennedy ends
up calling in blue Marvel into the Oval
Office he asked him to step down in the
interest of national security blue
Marvel does that and receives a
Presidential Medal of Freedom which he
ends up throwing away basically like you
wouldn't eating that whole origin story
if you guys never read The Legend of
blue Marvel you'll find a link to it
down in the description it's probably
one of the single greatest comic book
stories written in modern in the modern
era it is amazing but basically you
bring in Adam Brashear you get this
flashback film and you in the film in
such a way to where people are wondering
where's blue Marvel now what's he doing
now and maybe you show some post-credits
seen the show the audience hey he's
still around right like he's still
around here somewhere or whatever the
case is and and that's why I say you can
update it you can change it right like
you can you can you can respond to it in
different ways you can say okay well
instead of the civil rights era of the
1960's maybe it's some kind of other you
know civil rights unrest so like the LA
riots of 1992 and the president using
the insurrection Act of 1807 in order to
send in national troops I think that
using the civil rights movement is more
impactful I just don't really know how
you justify a guy who was in his 30s you
know during the era of the civil rights
and is only aged by like you know 20
years or 15 years uh I mean you could
just hide into his powers and just say
because of the nature of his powers he's
basically ageless right he's not really
immortal but he's like Wolverine he just
ages in a really slow rate and they
wouldn't work perfect but again these
are just some ideas that I have right so
if you guys enjoy this if you guys want
me to cover the the next films that
we're doing because in the next video
we'll do four more films and then in the
video after that we'll do five films
which includes Secret Wars so it's only
three three you know this is only three
videos long but let me know if you guys
want to see the other ones right and I'm
kind of curious let me know what you
guys think about this if you guys have
any kind of constructive criticism on
things that you would change let me know
down in the comments section but if you
guys are new here to comment explain
make sure you guys are the sub one to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
prease
[Music]
[Music]